Does absence make the
heart grow fonder?
New science says dating long
distance might make a better
relationship.
Hey distance daters,
welcome to "D News."
Trace here with
the science lowdown
on the dreaded long distance
relationship, or LDR.
Three million Americans
are part of an LDR.
25% to 50% of college students
are currently in one right now.
Of the non-college
group, reasons
could be military
deployment, work preferences
or requirements, internet
dating, and even immigration
and visa delays.
The internet helps
us feel closer,
even when we're far apart.
So long distance relationships
are growing in popularity.
Technology like text
messaging, instant messaging,
video chat, they all help
us feel a sense of inclusion
and intimacy that
we wouldn't have
been able to get only
10 or 15 years ago.
The research from
2010 says romance
does kind of require
face to face interaction.
Newer research, that's
saying the opposite.
A study in the Journal of
Sex and Marital Therapy
says, those in long
distance relationships
might actually be
better at dating.
Researchers recruited people
in close by and long distance
relationships, who filled out
a series of questionnaires
tackling their intimacy,
their commitment,
their communication,
psychological distress,
and sexual satisfaction,
or lack thereof.
Those in an LDR also
indicated how often
they got to see each other.
Though both groups
were doing well,
the LDR couples were
better functioning couples,
reporting higher levels
of satisfaction, intimacy,
and communication.
The close by couples win in
the area of getting laid more.
Basically, LDR couples
have to replace
their physical closeness
with emotional closeness.
While the close by
couples were overlooking
some of their problems,
the long distance couples,
they were forced
to sort them out.
A piece in Pacific
Magazine puts it this way.
"Long distance couples
are arguably better
at discussing sex, and
those who live nearby
actually have more sex."
A separate study this year in
the Journal of Communication
tipped the scales even farther
toward long distance couples,
indicating that they
form even deeper bonds
than their nearby
neighbors because of all
of that sharing,
something those of us who
are very familiar with
the long distance thing,
as my friends call
it, know very well,
because you're just
always talking,
you're just talking and talking,
and there's more talking
and some talking and talking.
In the end, all
this communication
leads to a greater sense
of mental intimacy, which
is great, if lonely.
Psychotherapist and
author, Rachel Sussman,
points out the loneliness factor
isn't really considered much
in this research, but it can
be really stressful for people,
which is a good point.
Also, they don't really
consider the jealousy factor.
If you're a jealous person
with a high level of FOMO,
things could go sour, fast.
"Lifehacker" has a
couple of helpful tips
to make LDR last, like
make date nights, where
you video chat,
eat dinner, watch
a movie, text things
like "wish you were here"
to alleviate jealousy.
And when you talk, be present.
Non-verbal cues are
really important.
Most importantly,
have an end date.
If there is no
end to the tunnel,
then there's no light
to look forward to.
What if some of the most
famous relationships were LDRs?
I wonder how like
Mary Todd Lincoln
would have tolerated
Abe's a brutal honesty?
The word "independence"
may have no A's in it.
The declaration
may have no holes.
But when you look at the
people who signed it,
there are a lot of a-holes.
That guy just does
not hold back.
Anyway, be sure to check out
brutally honest Abe for more
of his delightful truth bombs.
And tell us your thoughts
about the long distance
thing in the
comments area below.
And as always, subscribe
for more "D News" every day.
Thanks for watching.